[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
paf un peu particulier puisque on va
moins parler d'actualité que
d'itinéraires dit nirere singulier avec
mes invités alors garé en scène ce
bonjour je le président fondateur de all
three x qui est un réseau de vente en
ligne de vélo tout à fait un des plus
gros réseaux voix oui oui tout à fait on
effectivement spécialisée dans le
domaine du vélo et est maintenant la
course à pied est là où dort et voilà
vous
notre métier c'est proposer tout ce qui
englobe la pratique de ces disciplines
là donc on va de l'équipement du
pratiquant casque maillots chaussures en
passant par le vélo et tous ses
accessoires jusqu'à maintenant des
objets connectés montres etc pour
pouvoir pratiquer maintenant le sport
est connecté pouvoir avoir des
témoignages cessé de le mignan bonjour
vous êtes l'une des fondatrices de la
troupe les fugace de théâtre
qui joue beaucoup sur les mots la poésie
et vous venez d'ouvrir un centre à gan b
un centre culturel alors où il ya des
acteurs des des auteurs de théâtre comme
vous et puis de la population qui peut
venir c'est un centre on ouvre la
culture à la population est plus que
venir même c'est grâce c'est grâce aussi
aux habitants qu'on a réussi à ouvrir ce
lieu
donc il s'appelle le lieu et qui est
issu d'une rencontre entre la compagnie
et fugace à travers un projet de
territoire qui s'appelle escapade où on
a fait des spectacles dans les villages
et on a rencontré plein plein plein
d'habitants et à l'issue de ce projet on
avait tout un groupe de gens autour de
nous et plein d'envié plein d'énergie et
ça a donné l'ouverture du lieu il ya
maintenant 2 en 2h02 dre louise de lieu
de résidence du coup on accueille des
artistes qui viennent travailler et
grâce à la présence des artistes qui
viennent travailler on crée des
événements artistiques et culturelles
dans le village de grand baie et dans
les villages alentour aussi l'idée c'est
vraiment de rayonner sur le territoire
puisqu'on est sur une partie des
yvelines qui est très rurale et c'est
justement c'est ça qui est intéressant
au palace comment diffuser la culture
dans des territoires qui seront un peu
pauvre structurellement enfin dans ce
domaine là et puis ils n'auraient lake
louise
bonjour connu sous le nom de nono vous
faites partie de déclic théâtre fourbe
et on se souvient par là de quoi ou sont
passé ta mentale et beaucoup d'autres
vous maintenant alors vous avez commencé
par faire de l'improvisation et
maintenant vous renseigner on peut
l'improvisation
oui tout à fait un déclic théâtre c'est
une compagnie effectivement qu'il ya
plus de vingt ans maintenant bientôt
vingt-cinq vert et
un drap qui attrapent qui est née sous
l'impulsion comme vous l'avez dit de
l'un des doyens de gua et jb chauvin qui
on voit la structure est une compagnie
de théâtre après avoir après un projet
municipal qui arrivait à bout pour
pouvoir faire perdurer la pratique de
l'improvisation et est en fait cette
pratique de l'improvisation à trappes du
match d'improvisation voilà aujourd'hui
s'inscrit un peu comme culture à part
entière deux êtres terroir urbain et ça
et ça commence dès l'école dès le
collège on voyait un territoire donné
que c'est un championnat intercollèges
puisque ça ça a été lancé depuis
quelques années ça continuez vous vous
coacher les participants notamment à
sept reprises et puis vous faites aussi
de la province tout à fait exactement
alors x alors vous vous êtes vous avez
été un coureur de ses pistes de de
quelle spécialité
alors je pense que touche à toutes les
disciplines du vélo mais
particulièrement le vtt vtt j'ai
commencé à 7 8 ans
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'âge de 20 ans l'attend
et à 20 ans vous avez puis le nonce à
l'huile 4 mètres sur la tête en vélo et
donc je suis fracturé la nuque en trois
morceaux la colonne et donc c'est une
tuile qui ressemble à un an de pital
après chaise roulante réapprendre à
marcher donc j'ai stoppé les cours
évidemment et puis à l'issue de sa j'ai
décidé d'entreprendre
je me suis dit on n'a qu'une vie c'est
genre d'épisodes qui vous remet les
choses à remettre les choses en place et
la bombe a eu du temps pour réfléchir si
je peux dire de réfugiés et on voit le
bon côté pour découvrir l'informatique
en fait break -une fidesz est un outil
qui j'en hôpital se pratique très
facilement et donc j'ai découvert
internet has pour l'instant né en 2003
et puis j'ai eu envie de faire autre
chose et donc j'ai créé une première
société à l'issue de sa puis une seconde
qui m'ont forgé construit sur sur plein
de domaines et notamment le e-commerce
et en 2008 suis pas rancunier je suis
bon j'ai envie de refaire de viol au
c'est quand même une discipline j'adore
et or de manière très cool maintenant on
peut jitrois trop petits garçons la voix
l'a réparé progressivement
j'ai commencé à en faire en 2008 et puis
du coup à
à être amené à devoir mais qui paie et
regardez un peu ce qui était devenu le
paysage
commercial on va dire sur ce secteur là
et puis ça m'a donné envie de me lancer
dans côté que c'est mais à ce moment là
et donc vous avez fondé holt et ce alors
tant que c'est un site internet où on
trouve notamment alors des vélos des
équipements sportifs et ça je crois que
si d'affaires enfin c'est assez
impressionnant c'est un peu plus de 60
quand je donne simplement il 60 millions
d'euros jamais tant rester à 55 mais
donc c'est pour ça que c'est une arme je
suis retourné un peu plus de 130
collaborateurs maintenant ils s'en
servent à la santé talent là et on va
c'est super ce que j'ai démarré dans un
garage tout serait et dix ans après on
est 130 avec une boîte qui s'est
structuré où on cultive vraiment ce
qu'on appelle starnaute l'anglais mais
le happy management maintenant donc
l'occasion comme le font beaucoup les
jeunes boîte dans ce secteur notamment
une piste de vélo interne en bois avec
des bosses et des virages relevés au
sein des bureaux et des vélos en libre
service et donc si on abandonne
s'oxygéner impôt national sur les ide on
peut faire du vélo à l'intérieur et vous
êtes tous exactement
on est à quelques pas d'ici dans le
centre de saint quentin en yvelines face
à montigny-le-bretonneux depuis un an et
demi maintenant et on est toujours resté
dans la vallée de chevreuse moi je te
souviens de chevreuse et en fait on a
déménagé 11 fois en tout en disant mais
dans le bide en coin de 5 10 km et donc
c'est vraiment une belle aventure est
effectivement comme vous disiez on a un
catalogue de 90 mille références ni
alors évidemment c'est ça l'avantagé car
nette hausse et ce n'est pas une
boutique qui propose le dixième ou le
centième de ce que vous proposez vous
non alors effectivement revient d'un
garage donc c'était beaucoup plus
minimaliste à l'époque et puis au fur et
à mesure on s'est agrandie remet
attendait une plateforme logistique en
propre et en eure et loir
on a dix sept mille mètres carrés dont
géré par 50 collaborateurs et donc au
quotidien on expédie des milliers de
commandes 560000 expédition l'année
dernière vers huit cent mille clients
france qui sont des passionnés de course
à pied et de vélo
de tracking et donc on suit au quotidien
est une promesse qui est très très forte
parce qu'en fait on a on a eu très peu
de fonds pour lancer l' aventure au
début et l'idée étant de capitaliser sur
l'expérience client sur un domaine qui
est communautaire donc les gens
pratiquent ensemble ils peuvent parler
dans de bonnes expériences
si tel est le cas l'idée c'était d'avoir
les produits en stock et les livres le
plus rapidement possible donc
aujourd'hui vous commander chez nous
avons 18 heures l'exposition par le soir
même et vous soyez en france en italie
au portugal en allemagne en espagne ou
équivalent lendemain à 9h elle s'est
laissée c'est c'est aussi bien sinon
mieux qu amazon
j'ai dit amazon parce que évidemment
vous êtes ces petits marche extrêmement
bien mais il ya en effet les géants
d'internet qu'il faut parfois qu'ils
prennent les les idées qui sont bonnes
mais comment on arrive à concurrencer et
vous fait extrêmement bien
c'est là je pense que la chance qu'on a
et qu'on cultive c'est que les gaffes à
comme vous dites sont devenus des
généralistes et des monstres et de fait
comme vous le suis attaques toutes les
catégories dont clairement on perd un
peu son âme et et les côtés ambiance que
vous pouvez trouver même sur un site
internet c'est ce qu'on travaille nos
quotidiens alors tonné sera domaine
souvent de passion chez vous ressentez
des spécialistes et des gens qui aiment
ça et que les gens et les 130 personnes
qui travaillent fait vous voilà c'est
des gens qui adorent le sport ou le vélo
qu'il faut des doctorants en vélo donc
vous aviez parce que sinon on s'en va
sonder sur un domaine qui est physique
très technique et comme on s'adresse à
des passionnés
on est les connaisseurs et à l'armée
face à des pratiquants qui sont très
pointus donc si vous êtes parent a
minima aussi pointus que perdez toute
crédibilité
donc ça déjà c'est une barrière à
l'entrée parce que parce qu'un amazon ou
moi généralise humeur générale pardon
généralistes
n'a pas vocation à être hyper
spécialistes et bien sûr et donc nous
voilà on avance là dedans et on a
préféré justement avancer sur d'autres
disciplines donc on a ouvert la course à
pied il ya trois ans et là où d'ordre
quand on parle de vous dans par le de
marche nordique de trekking et puis de
tout ce qui va avec ce sont les tentes
en altitude dont on a besoin les
réchauds pour pouvoir voilà s'est
lamenté etc
on a préféré rester un hyper
spécialistes sur plusieurs disciplines
maintenant plutôt que de venir un ultra
generali rallye vélo est effectivement
se retrouver trop en frontal avec des
acteurs du logiciel
non on va revenir sur le texte mais
c'est pas si on peut faire un parallèle
mais gary raconte et voilà qui l'accusé
d' accidents de la vie dans un accident
elle est donc on a l'impression que
l'improvisation et l'école
d'improvisation déclic théâtre notamment
s'adresse parfois aussi à des enfants d
accidents de la vie mais qui à l'école
sont pas forcément épanouie vous même ça
a été un peu votre cas des liens non
ouais moi j'étais épanouie à l'école 1
c'est pas le prêt mais je n'étais pas un
enfant voit avec n'en ai pas de oui mais
mais j'avais tourné vous exprimer j'ai
trouvé moins exprimer exprimer et de
et d'exister surtout n'existe et voilà
et je pense que ça c'est assez important
parce que quand on n'existe pas
nécessairement par les études au milieu
scolaire on peut avoir des résultats
moyens et être complètement voilà dans
cette masse nébuleuses ou ou personnes
nous regardent finalement où tout va
bien et il n'ya pas des serments de
concentration ou des professeurs ou de
l'institution sur nous moi j'étais un
petit peu dans ce cas là je faisais pas
de bruit et quand j'ai commencé à
l'improvisation c'est vrai que tout d'un
coup
devenu quelqu'un venu quelqu'un parce
que finalement et en maths et en sport
voilà il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas
nécessairement le j'avais pas forcément
les qualités pour pour exister
et c'est vrai que l'improvisation si ça
avait été du théâtre plus classique et
bien en fait dans un univers comme celui
de trappes ou ailleurs d'ailleurs je
pense pas que tu rappes soit il je pense
pas qu'ils aient nécessairement le
besoin de faire le focus mai mais en
tout cas pour pour pour moi bon bah je
lisais mais bon tu es mal j'avais pas
nécessairement j'ai pas j'ai pas eu des
facilités à la lecture des facilités à
l'apprentissage et je pense que je
serais pas allé naturellement verviers
vous avez dit faut jouer du molière
d'abord j'ai appris avec ma prof de
français à l'époque voyageurs le médecin
malgré lui et je le remercie mes beauce
et s était pas très jolie ma manière de
jouer en europe
j'ai découvert molière par le biais de
l'improvisation c'est vrai que le jouer
à la manière de molière il posé mes mots
à moi créer moi-même mon texte et
développer voilà les farces tels que moi
je les imaginais avec mes camarades
finalement c'était plus simple parce que
finalement comme il y avait pas texte
j'étais sûr sur la même ligne de départ
que les autres pour faire du théâtre
quoi je pense que la réussite de djamel
s'il est un exemple youtube alliot marie
a remercié pas passée par la compagnie
mais il y en a plein d'autres en tout
cas
mais même pour ceux qui ne sont pas
connus mais mais c'est surtout qu'en
fait on s'est retrouvé là à pouvoir
faire du théâtre même titre que les
autres par le biais de l'improvisation
et par le biais de l'improvisation parce
que c'est noté a très justement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous sortirez armé pour
jouer le médecin malgré lui par exemple
moi là comme ça là la question un peu
trop difficile que les tout au fait que
les femmes et trois points des verts
n'ont pas tout de suite pour essayer de
retrouver l'homme et quoi qu'il en soit
où il me sentirai armées vont avec aussi
un moyen d'apprendre d'avoir confiance
en soi on a monté le songe d'une nuit
d'été avec la compagnie déclic théâtre
etc que des comédiens pour la plupart
issus de saint-quentin-en-yvelines qu'on
avait rencontré ou dans les
établissements scolaires ou dans nos
ateliers d'improvisation on a été
accompagnée avec des comédiens voilà les
parisiens qui ont déjà une carrière très
riche et qui sont venus nous accompagner
et qui nous ont permis de monter cette
pièce j'ai eu 15 représentations entre
coignières trappe elancourt voilà et
puis oui
donc on est capable déclic théâtre à
monter lysistrata on a fait des
créations théâtrales l'improvisation ce
n'est pas une fin en soi au sein de la
compagnie loin de là
c'est une manière plus comme je disais
c'est un chemin de traverse pour pour
aller faire d'autres choses pour se
découvrir soi-même ou cij a parce que
normalement on n'a pas qu'on appelle
nécessairement certes y'a plein de
parcours le mien on est est une chose
très particulière j'ai eu la chance de
profiter aussi du du des dispositifs
d'état pour pouvoir prendre un poste à
déclic et développer aussi bon et
maintenant
maintenant il ya énormément de comédiens
qui travaillent au sein de déclic
théâtre au jour le jour pour faire de la
formation théâtrale pour faire de la
formation d'improvisation ou ou pour
développer des projets il y en a qu'on
travaille en télé y en a qu'on travaille
et voilà pour faire de la présentation
du team building en entreprise il ya
énormément irizar débouchés
mon à pister puis l'improvisation
effectivement aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est très demandé
dans le milieu parce que ça permet ça
permet d'aller d'aller très vite une
manière assez efficace en tout c'est que
tout va de plus en plus vite
les vélos aussi d'ailleurs avec
l'électricité commencé tout va être plus
en plus vite
effectivement l'improvisation ça permet
une écriture rapide et efficace je veux
pas qu'elle est meilleure que l'autre
montre qu'elle est rapide et efficace
elle est en tout cas où il vient de bien
dans ce temps de sauter du temps parce
que le parallèle que faisait c'est que
au fond ben voila vous aussi c'est un
parcours particulier vous n'avez pas
sais pas je ne pense pas vous pas fait
d'études voilà du coup non jegun visite
donc soit là mais je suis très fier j'ai
un bac es
vous avez vous aviez une connaissance de
2 du produit que vous vouliez lancée
mais moi j'ai pas fait beaucoup de bruit
à l'école n'ont plus faim papa le bon en
tout cas sinon et j'ai un père qui est
graphiste une marque et psychologues
dont j'étais assez loin de la fibre
commerciale en tout cas transmises par
les parents et mais j'ai toujours aimé
ça et effectivement la passion du
produit aussi à fait que je suis
pourquoi pas réunir les deux et je pense
que quand on oui je pense quand on les
parcourt peut-être un peu singulier
christau singulier ou des tuiles et dans
la vie
ça fait évoluer intellectuellement ou
les choses différemment et puis en plus
de ça ça décuple une énergie chez vous
enfin moi aujourd'hui j'ai encore un peu
de matériel médical sur la colonne etc
mais je me suis jamais senti aussi en
forme et plein d'énergie et plein
d'ambition et alors là lavier super et
il est quelles que soient par contre on
ait pu avoir en amont c'est à des choses
qu on va parler un petit peu de comment
fonctionne quand vous l'avez créé vous
étiez encore sur votre lit d'hôpital
vous rêviez à ce que c'est devenu
aujourd'hui j'ai pas fini
quand j'ai créé la première structure
j'étais effectivement encore sur mon lit
d'hôpital
j'ai pu mais de mes deux premières
structures étaient plus modeste qu'on
veut le tricks qui je l'espère encore
plein plein de choses non absolument pas
j'ai des marraines hall tricks dans le
garage de mon père et 6000 euros
je faisais des gens et de 8 à 23 heures
où je finissais mes colis à quatre
pattes au sol pour scotcher être à
l'heure à la poste
j'emmenais mes colis à pied puisque le
volume était tout petit au départ je
redonne à des poids lourds qui partent
chaque soir avec nos expéditions
donc non je n'ai pas du tout vu mais
après c'est extraordinaire aussi parce
qu'en fait nos métiers mon métier en
interne change tous les six mois
oui on lui a pourri filet
j'ai toujours dessiné par par par brique
mais c'est sa dévolution constantin et
ses expériences faites il faut
structurer l'entreprise vous déménagez
11 fois il faut apprendre à c'est pas
drôle au début et puis après c'est un
jeu il faut apprendre à les rendre aussi
extérieure pour récupérer
la confiance de vos banques
d'investisseurs on parlera peut-être
comment comment on investit et des
nouveaux collaborateurs sans perdre la
culture d'entreprise que vous avez des
cantons des 130 c'est pas pareil que
quand un tout petit groupe au début j'ai
nommé et pourtant je pense que mail
energy sera toujours aussi beau et aussi
forte il faut qu'on arrive à garder ce
format de start-up garde du père ça me
fait penser un peu mais c'est vrai que
toutes ces entreprises qui sont et qui
sont aujourd'hui alors ça a été comme ça
des rêves de gamin qui travaillaient
avec leurs noms mais change de mains moi
beaucoup de startups qui démarre de rien
sans ténacité super que c'est une start
up trucks est dans l'état d'esprit on
continue de se qualifier comme ça et je
pense que typiquement enfin la piste de
vélo en interne et l'amèneront
fonctionne trés le démontre mais c'est
un état d'esprit ça ne respecte et ça
c'est plus un état d'esprit qu'une
structure et johan micoud enfin cécile
molinier alors c'est un peu la même
chose c'est-à-dire que vous aussi dans
un lieu un peu hostile comme ça c'est un
peu dit vous essayez de changer les
choses
d'abord le l'accompagné l'efficace alors
ça commençait vous étiez amateurs au
début alors la compagnie efficace elle a
usé des trois cités ouais on est et on
était plus nombreuse au long des deux et
on travaille la spécificité depuis le
début depuis la création de la compagnie
en 2008 c'est le travail en espace
public on fait du théâtre en espace
public qui a une notion qui parlent pas
forcément parce que c'est toujours en
espèces le théâtre est un espace public
mais là disons espace public ouvert mais
on travaille d'autres qui est demandeur
doit le dire dans des structures qui
sont pas de travail à l'extérieur dans
les rues exactement
on travaille et de ces dernières années
on a développé une spécificité même qui
est le théâtre en déambulation donc le
principe c'est que les spectateurs se
promènent pour suivre le spectacle et
que les comédiens amateurs ou
professionnels en fonction des
spectacles ils ont fait des créations
professionnelles avec des comédiens
professionnels et on
et aussi des créations avec des
habitants ça du coup les comédiens
racontent l'histoire ou en tout cas
déroule le spectacle tout au long d'une
promenade dans des lieux et du coup on
utilise vraiment on essaye de s'appuyer
sur l'espace public pour raconter nos
histoires et utiliser vraiment les
décors dans lesquels on passe au
quotidien pour en faire tout d'un coup
un décor de l'imaginaire et c'est ça
donne des choses très jolie parce que
dans la partie plus travail de
territoire ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon culturel le travail de territoire
c'est-à-dire tout ce qu'on fait ici dans
les yvelines
on a notamment travaillé donc dans le
projet scapa dont je parlais tout à
l'heure dans des villages où on est
resté pendant trois mois nous une équipe
professionnelle et on a bossé avec les
habitants qui avaient envie de
participer qui ont certains jouets
certains construit certains fait de la
musique en fonction de leurs envies et
on a transformé le village en un lieu de
spectacle pendant toute une soirée et du
coup ça donne des souvenirs aux gens qui
passent tous les jours par le même rond
point pour emmener leurs enfants à
l'école il se trouve que ce rond point
le jour du spectacle c'était le
rond-point de l'exaucer y avait un
comédien un habitant qui était tout en
haut du rond-point il y avait neuf cents
ballons gonflés qui transformait ce rond
point en un nuage blanc
voilà donc on essaye vraiment de
travailler sur les belges la marque sa
marque ensuite le tld c'est vraiment on
utilise
donc donc l'accompagner les fugace à la
base avait cette envie là travailler
dehors aussi parce que pour nous
j'entends un écho du boulot que vous
faites pour nous le théâtre l'art le
spectacle vivant en tout cas est aussi
et surtout un outil de mise en relation
avec les gens de lien social
ce qu'on travaille nous en tant
qu'acteur en tant qu'artiste au
spectacle vivant
que ce soit la présence la relation
toutes ces notions qui font le théâtre
qui font vraiment le boulot des acteurs
c'est des choses qu'on aime à partager
parce qu'on estime que ça a c'est le
ciment en fait de la relation sociale
dans une mesure beaucoup plus globale et
en dehors juste du cercle artistique et
donc quand on est arrivé ici en 2011
quand donc la compagnie basée à gars lui
qu'un petit village a été de gambe et à
la base
et quand on est arrivé à guelmim moi
j'ai fait un peu le constat
effectivement que bas niveau culturel il
y avait
il y avait du boulot concernant
particulièrement spectacle vivant c'est
une zone une sorte de il ya des lieux
dans le territoire de passion pour le
territoire qui sont où il ya beaucoup
d'offres culturelles et des aides
c'était complètement le constat qu'on a
fait et avec des problématiques qui sont
très spécifiques c'est à dire que par
chez nous les habitants traînent
beaucoup leur voiture pour aller
travailler pour aller année les enfants
pour taratata et le week end ils ont pas
nécessairement l'énergie de se faire 25
30 40 km pour venir notamment par
exemple ici à saint quentin il ya un
théâtre qui lui fit programmation mais
la question est pas la qualité de
l'équipement elle est la distance et les
usages en fait des habitants et puis
peut-être pleut parfois c'est pour ça
qu'au s'il le fait d'être un extérieur
j'ai aussi peut-être parfois pour un
certain nombre de gens une sorte de
crainte d'aller le nem pousser la porte
d'un théâtre il ya surtout un théâtre
comme comme solides 50 à l'habitude
c'est rigolo parce que on est on est
nous dans une partie du département qui
est plutôt relativement favoriser au
niveau social
mais en fait les questions d' habitude
culturelle se retrouve exactement la
même manière que dans des quartiers plus
populaires c'est-à-dire les gens n'ont
pas l'habitude
d'ailleurs ça les sacs en tissu de
l'arabie que je coure d'aller au théâtre
et c'est pas une question d'argent c'est
une question d'habitude beaucoup de
fractures sociales mais il ya eu aussi
une fracture culturelle complète quand
vous vous servez des lieux pour écrire
une histoire vous partez des lieux où
est ben du coup en l'occurrence là le
lieu dans lequel on est actuellement
c'est un des annexes d'une ancienne
maison de retraite
du coup ce sont des bâtiments qui sont
au coeur de la forêt dans un endroit
vraiment oui c'est pas la maison oui on
aime on est vraiment dans quelques jeux
de l'armée dans une rue râle rural c'est
roddick en bourse aujourd'hui
alors on a lancé on est de l'autre côté
du village est effectivement comme comme
on est sur un projet qui a priori un
projet mobile c'est-à-dire le projet
c'est l'association c'est à dire c'est
un groupe de gens d'artistes et
d'habitants qui se réunissent pour se
dire on a envie de proposer des choses
au plus proche de nos habitations de nos
familles parce que on a envie de nos
familles connaissent ce que c'est
participer à un spectacle voir un
spectacle être touché par une scène par
un comédien et donc tous ces gens là se
sont réunies pour faire quelque chose il
se trouve qu'on a trouvé ces bâtiments
qui étaient là et nous l'aura qu'il
accueillerait christ est la compagne et
moi on vient dans notre prime jeunesse
de la culture en premier lieu de squat
est un peu plus tard de l'occupation
légal avec cette idée là de dire si les
bâtiments sont vides occupons les et
écrivons un projet d'occupation qui
valorise l'histoire et la topologie du
bâtiment donc là par exemple on
réfléchit à éventuellement déménager
dans un avenir proche ou lointain parce
qu'on sait qu'on est sur des dynamiques
qui sont assez précaire et il est
question peut-être un moment donné
d'aller vers des fermes parce qu'il ya
une problématique sur les fermes six
sont des territoires parce qu'avec
grande ferme qui sont en attente de
projets alors si on va investir une
ferme
qu'est ce qu'on raconte comme projet
spécifique par rapport à un ce lieu-là
qui est très particulier a une histoire
très particulière et ça va
nécessairement modifier un peu notre
projet j'ai une question un peu terre à
terre mais comment vous payez qui
financièrement parce que c'est leur
métier s'est bêtement alors du coup moi
je sais pas vraiment
très radicalement mon activité de
compagnie et mon activité l'activité sur
le lieu puisque mon actif des compagnies
c'est mon métier je gagne ma vie avec
les spectacles qu'on fait avec le projet
de territoire etc et l'activité du lieu
c'est mon engagement d'artistes de ce
territoire et de citoyennes qui a envie
de partager le savoir faire et
l'expertisé culturelle que moi je peux
amener avec des gens qui ont envie de
donner leur énergie à ça après le lieu
en lui-même
depuis un an maintenant en fait c'est
tout est allé très vite
on a ouvert le lieu avec 4000 euros qui
était une levée de fonds citoyenne sur
internet qui sont des sous qui nous ont
permis à réhabiliter parce qu'il faut
vous figurez qu'on est rentré dans un
bâtiment qui était abandonné depuis 15
ans dont les fenêtres étaient restées
ouvertes donc y avait des champignons
sur les murs étaient vraiment dans un
état donc on a fait un an de travaux
avec vraiment très peu d'argent est en
fait on a commencé à accueillir des
compagnies qui viennent de la france
entière travailler chez nous puis comme
ça prenait de l'ampleur on s'est dit bah
alors ces compagnies qui viennent
travailler chez nous plutôt que de leur
proposer de montrer leur travail en
public dans le jardin chez nous on va
leur proposer aussi d'aller dans les
villages autour et c est ça en fait à
attirer l'attention beaucoup des
tutelles ce qu'on appelle les tutelles
donc le ministère la région le
département le parc naturel régional qui
est un allié formidable dans toutes ses
aventures et donc tous ces gens là
maintenant contribuer au financement
cette année
cette année le lieu à un budget de 50
mille euros donc on n'est pas assez de
on n'est pas dans les échelles mais on
est passé de 4000 euros il ya deux ans à
50 millions d'années qui n'est pas de
l'argent qui nous sert à nous payer nous
on reste bénévole mais qui est de
l'argent qui sert à faire fonctionner
quelqu'un qui coordonne les actions et
qui a les salariés et puis ça me permet
de payer les artistes quand on leur
propose de faire des sorties de
résidence publique dans lé village
puisque ça c'est en dehors de leur temps
de création pure c'est vraiment aussi un
temps qui dédie aussi à générer de
l'activité sur le territoire et
l'accueil de la population et les super
alors ouais on a pour base les gens qui
regardent on en a toujours un petit peu
qui se demande on essaye d'être 1100 ces
gens là bas on est un peu hors cadre
c'est sûr qu'on ressente pas tellement à
ce qu'ils ont l'habitude de voir au
quotidien
mais par ailleurs depuis qu'on a
commencé à travailler et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on n'a jamais eu aucun
problème de fréquentation sur nos
événements ce qui pour moi est un une
dimension hyper symbolique ça raconte de
fait c'est moi quand je suis arrivé ici
en 2000
en 2008 on j'allais voir les villages
pour leur dire venez on fait des choses
et tous me disais non mais quand on fait
des événements n'a personne ça fait rien
on n'y arrive pas on mobilise pas les
habitants ça les intéresse pas moi
depuis qu'on a commencé en 2011 et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a toujours du
monde on a au moins 70 80 personnes à
tous nos événements
quand vous êtes sur un rond-point vont
faire un nuage oui alors du coup il ya
sur les sur les projets de territoires
comme ça ça communique de soi même parce
qu'en fait comme on répète dehors et
qu'on est là pendant trois mois et qu'on
travaille avec les habitants en fait ça
fait ça fait que tout le monde se sent
concerné parce que c'est un projet du
village c'est pas un projet d'une
campagne hors sol qui arrive qui
travaillent qui repart vers d'intégrer
on est vraiment dedans et après on a une
newsletter aujourd'hui on a on a je
crois qu'on a presque mille adhérents
aujourd'hui à l'association
donc c'est 1000 personnes qui reçoivent
la newsletter
quand on a des événements a annoncé on a
un facebook est aussi très alimenté et
tout ça fait que voilà il ya un vrai
intérêt pour le travail qu'on fait elle
s'appelle le lieu à gambais et il ya un
documentaire qui est qui a été consacré
à cette troupe votre activité s'appelle
les gens doutent vous proposons d'en
voir un petit extrait et je reparle
après nous sommes les gens du lieu
des bénévoles de tous âges et de tous
horizons
trente personnes artistes professionnels
et habitants des îles
nous nous sommes rencontrés en
participant à des spectacles de la
compagnie les fugace le collectif les
gens du lieu est née en septembre 2015
en découvrant les bâtiments de la
mutuelle ratp nous avions le désir de
réhabiliter cet endroit en lieu de
création artistique
après un an de travaux bénévoles le lieu
ouvre enfin ses portes pour son
inauguration
plus de 400 visiteurs sont au rendez
vous un succès sur ce territoire des
villes classées par le ministère aux
zones prioritaires de développement
culturel
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le lieu propose une salle de
répétition des ateliers de création et d
espace d'accueil et de vie collective
ici professionnels et amateurs peuvent
bénéficier d'un cadre agréable pour
développer leurs projets inventer
construire créer rêver cette année le
lieu accueille seize projets comédiens
musiciens plasticiens auteurs danseurs
peintre botaniste des sorties de
résidence sont organisées spectacles
concerts expositions pour le grand
plaisir des habitants de grand baie et
des environs alors là on a on a vu le
lieu tel qu'il était quand vous êtes
arrivé on a vu beaucoup de d'instruments
m'inquiétais pas seulement des actions
de terrain ponceuse karcher donc et
c'est quand même oui ça c'était une
réussite assez rapide au fond c'est
assez fou vous même voie bleue quand il
écrit sans surprise mais vous aussi aux
fonds non en fait à la base on cherchait
un espace de stockage pour les jours
pour les affaires de la compagnie
c'était ça le besoin de départ à huawei
est en fait les gens du parc naturel
mais il ya ces bâtiments ils sont
abandonnés
on est allé voir moi j'suis allé
rencontrer le président de la mutuelle
ratp qui s'appelle monsieur pouliot qui
est un type formidable d'une humanité
qui nous a suivis qui nous a aidés qui
nous accompagnent encore aujourd'hui
d'une façon assez remarquable et on lui
a je vais présenter le projet avec cette
expertise que moi j'avais par le passé
d'occupation temporaire puisque on a
avec laura on a co créé une association
qu'il avait le cul rima bar à paris qui
fait exactement ça faire de l'occupation
temporaire de bâtiments qui sont en
attente de projets immobiliers est donc
là je viens dire un mot très important
qui le mot temporaire
haut lieu on est sur un bail précaire ça
veut dire qu'on ne paye pas de loyer
on a pris les bâtiments en l'état c'est
pour ça que vous avez vu avec les 6 es
étang qui dit temporaire dit
potentiellement quinze jours devra
partir donc on conçoit vraiment ce
projet là comme un projet mobile avec
aujourd'hui on a un projet de
développement du lieu sur le grand
bâtiment qui est juste derrière nos
bâtiments actuels qui est l'ancienne
maison de retraite qui est le bâtiment
central en fait là de la parcelle
c'était le mec tu vois là nous on april
annexes il ya là il ya deux un peu plus
de 100 m² le bâtiment central lui fait
1600 mètres oui enfin c'est la
présentation de ce projet là et là
l'idée ce serait de développer quelque
chose qui croise le volet culturel que
nous on développe avec d'autres usages
pour essayer d'inventer ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui qui est un mot très en vogue
un tir lieu c'est à dire un lieu qui qui
va générer différents usages pour que ce
lieu culturel soit ouvert donc dans
l'idée du tiers du tir a lieu qu'on a
écrit paul du xxl donc pour ce bâtiment
là parce que comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure
chaque bâtiment applique un projet écrit
spécifiquement pour lui donc si un jour
vous n'avez accès par d'anciens journée
avec 16 bâtiments là celui là l'idée ce
serait de créer un restaurant en lien
avec un maraîcher qui pourrait
s'installer sur le site puisqu'il ya
sept hectares de terrain dont quatre
hectares de forêt avec un espace de
coworking puisqu'il a été démontré par
une étude qui a été qui a été
commanditée par la communauté de
communes ya quelques années qu'il ya un
besoin de cover king expressément à cet
endroit là de la communauté de communes
donc avec moi là l'idée d'avoir quelque
chose de protéiforme avec des petits
des petits volumes pour chaque activité
qui puisse répondre répondre à la
réalité de notre territoire on n'est pas
à saint quentin en yvelines on va pas
ouvrir 800 m² de coworking ça n'aurait
pas de sens en revanche son 12 200 ou
250 m² à l'image du 50 couverts
quilliams rsa ça fonctionnerait parce
qu'il ya un besoin pour ça donc voilà
l'idée ce serait amérique c'est un
projet politique complètement moi je
défends complètement
voilà on parle beaucoup de politique
culturelle
comment comment fait on met là en plein
centre de la société moi je veux
vraiment je mon travail à moi en tout
cas je trouve ça super ça existe par
ailleurs même mon travail à moi et il
est d'aller mettre des artistes au coeur
de la société de vraiment chercher la
porosité comment on fait en sorte que
les gens se sentent complètement
familier avec une équipe artistique qui
vont travailler que ce soit naturel
d'aller voir un spectacle que ce soit
voilà comment qu'on est ce assez pour
les lectures comme lien social aussi
c'est complètement politique non
oui j'ai juste pour rebondir parce que
c'est vrai qu'on fait de la politique
sans le vouloir mais une acquis une
action culturelle réussie c'est une
action culturelle qui amène un nouveau
public qui a dû public qui vient voir du
spectacle régulièrement mais toucher des
publics qui sont pas nécessairement des
habitués au spectacle c'est une action
culturelle réussite parce que finalement
hélas hélas c'est de la politique parce
qu'on cherche des adhérents à notre
projet et finalement les gens qui
viennent pour une première fois qu'ils
vont revenir revenir c'est réussir à
faire adhérer un un projet
une histoire actuellement donc forcément
on fait de la politique parce que comme
comme un acteur de politique on va
communiquer pour les lectures attirer la
politique
l'étiologie voilà c'est la question de
savoir comment ensemble et quand même si
bien ensemble et comment on a envie
d'être ensemble
typiquement nous ce qu'on fait c'est de
dire aux gens alors du coup qu'est ce
qu'on fait du commun il ya l'individu à
la propriété privée il ya chacun sa vie
son métier sa famille etc
c'est hyper important mais il ya un
commun on vit ensemble on vit dans le
même village on emprunte les mêmes rues
on passe les week-ends au même endroit
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça comment
comment on crée et moi l'exemple le plus
beau que je peux tirer de toute cette
histoire c'est qu'un gars lui où on
était implanté en premier lieu on a créé
un événement qui s'appelait la fête des
lumières qu'on a fait cinq fois qu'était
un spectacle participatif
aujourd'hui ce sont organisés tout seul
ils ont plus de monde aujourd'hui un
collectif d'habitants qui a créé un
projet de tricot urbain hyper ambitieux
que vous avez reçus ici à t110 il ya
quelques mois et ce sont les habitants
en autonomie tout seul qui se sont
organisés et aujourd'hui c'est un
village qui hyper dynamique dans lequel
il ya des temps conviviaux il ya une vie
de village il ya une vraie vie de
village et moi pour moi c'est l'exemple
juste ford du fait que nous on impulse
mais quand même l'énergie les larmes
juste des révélateurs c'est un peu la
même chose que des critères est-ce que
déclic théâtre aurait pu réussir à haïr
4 ap
probablement mais mais mais c'est lié
quand même un milieu qui était pas non
plus forcément très ouvert aux cultures
oui on aurait réussi ça y est on a
réussi on est symptomatique que ça soit
1 ouvrira vicieux autre l'aurait le
réussir ça à trappes
on a réussi on est là sur saint quentin
en yvelines sur un sur un territoire en
friche au départ c'est une ville
nouvelle construite sur effectivement
sur des fermes sur et moi je vois
beaucoup de similitudes donc dans
l'étrier
de ce qui peut de ce qui peut être
existé dans 20 ans ou dans trente ans
chez vous mais mais c'est vrai que là où
là où on réussit à trappes ont réussi
parce qu'il ya où il ya eu aussi
effectivement une genèse qui étaient en
demande à des moments donnés et qui est
bart de wever ça aussi de la culture
enfin c'est aussi une bouffée d'oxygène
ou c'est à dire ce qu'on a montré que ce
n'était pas fait que pour les autres ça
m'allait soit pour parler reconnaissance
pour les déconner il ya deux mois celui
du diable viens viens improvisé c'est
comme ça que ça a débuté en fin tout à
fait et puis au départ il n'était pas là
pour pour faire l'impro quoi ils étaient
là pour embêter son c'est ça et
effectivement ils se retrouvent là pris
dans une espèce de spirale qui va lui
montrer qu'en fait il a des choses à
raconter qu'il est intéressant qu'il est
qu'il est écouté sur tout et ça et ça à
chaque fois qu'on arrive à écouter à nos
jeunes à trappes et qui a une audience
pour pour rigoler de leur bêtise plutôt
que pour punir ou pour sanctionner ou
pour dire attends attends attends voilà
on est dans quelque chose on va
positiver des attitudes qui d'habitude
sont sont des crimes et après on réussit
à trappes parce que effectivement dans
ce microcosme que peut être trappe
effectivement ça fait focus mais en vrai
oui on aurait réussi ailleurs il avait
caché car d'improvisateur qui
réussissent bien j'avais partout en
france aujourd'hui
mais c'est pas un hasard
ouais c'est ça non mais c'est super ça
d'avoir d'avoir ça en fer de lance quoi
de la notoriété de déclic théâtre est ce
que c'est pas aussi peut-être un
handicap parce que du coup ça ne vient
pas quelque chose un peu d'un timide au
pourtour des gens à ce qu'il y ait les
fesses de pression quand on quand on a
deux quand on a des jeunes qui viennent
et qui ont qui sont pleins d'ambitions
c'est vrai qu'ils viennent avec une
espèce de pression à la pression a peut
être vu de deux manières on peut 0 ils
ont la pression du coup c'est pas cool
ils sont pas détendu ouais mais en même
temps cette pression là de dire il ya eu
quand même quelques exemples qui sont
pas c'est pareil il faut qu'on soit bon
faut pas qu on déconne aussi à willis
viennent ils viennent voilà c'est ça il
y en a gagné effectivement le respect de
deux de ces jeunes là et ça c'est
important parce que du coup nous ça nous
facilite le travail va nous faciliter
l'accompagnement qu'on peut faire parce
que finalement on a en a un peu dégagé
tous les problèmes que pouvais tu
pouvais être drainée mais moi je pense
que on est dans un système quand même
ouh ouh c'est donnant donnant donc que
donne nous de nous de dota matières
premières et puis nous on va structurer
les choses pour que cette matière-là ce
puisse être mise en avant écouté entendu
et puis peut-être voilà ça après tu te
mets la pression si tu veux mais en tout
cas tu as my town ici ou là dans la vie
vous y êtes arrivé comment moi j'ai
commencé à moi je suis un exemple je
suis un prototype
complet de la compagnie moi j'ai connu
alain degois dents quand il est
éducateur sportif au canoë kayak aux
éclaireurs de france
moi je faisais du canoë et par hasard
l'année d'après en sixième jeu les
retrouver au sein du collège il était là
il déambulait et puis il est venu dans
ma classe pour proposer des ateliers
c'était un cadeau module de français il
avait dû avoir un financement comme ça
pour pour nous initier et il a beaucoup
il a beaucoup cherché des financements
mais ça mettrait à part entière c'est à
dire que c'est un moi j'adore l'homme
j'adore le comédien mais c'était enfin
cet essai un quelqu'un qui est qui qui
qui qui qui sait aussi parler de ce qui
fait et qui sait mettre en avant et qui
sait aller chercher des fonds pour
pouvoir aller s'était surtout l'eau
c'était avant là où s'est engagé dit
c'était parce que j'étais grand place et
sait comment ça vanne là alors il c'est
géraldine orquera qui est directrice de
la compagnie
et puis après voilà y'a l'hérault il ya
des comédiens associés puis à toute la
partie radio aussi avec marmite fm
ah oui aux guérillas mois et il ya
effectivement un pool de comédiens qui
travaille à la réflexion autour de
l'improvisation et de la création à
déclic donc je vous ai coupé vous êtes
arrivé oui donc oui moi je suis arrivé à
paris car ensuite voilà par hasard dans
mon estime dit bah ouais c'est rigolo ce
que tu fais va bien on a un atelier le
midi là voilà puis je me suis inscrit
dans le cadre de l'atelier donc tous les
midis j'allais manger vite fait chez moi
puis je revenais et puis et puis
finalement ça m'a plu le kayak j'ai mis
ça de côté
très rapidement et en fait j'ai compris
que ça va donner leur avis ouais ça ça
que j'avais envie de faire c'est ça que
j'avais en huitième puis faire du fer
d'improvisation faire du kayak je pense
que j'étais honoré un original de toute
façon dans la salle j'ai pris les j'ai
pas fais du foot et et la comédie mais
j'étais voilà dans des choses un peu un
peu de travers et puis après chemin
faisant au lycée tout ça je me suis
retrouvée au sein de l'association a
mené déjà des petits ateliers à à
déplacer la patinoire
à récupérer la clé aller chercher le
code les donner à quelqu'un d'autre
voilà toutes les petites choses
attendues utile je me suis rendu utile
puis à l'époque fallait se rendre utile
parce que on envoyait des newsletters
fallait coller les timbrés c'était un
travail de petites mains quand même
réussir la communication donc
effectivement avec les jeunes de la
compagnie on était là à squatter les
bureaux de déclic puis on était contents
nous d'être là parce que finalement il y
avait des gâteaux et et du thé donc et
puis ont collé des teintes tout
l'après-midi à se raconter des bêtises
et mais c'est vraiment une histoire
d'effervescence quoi tout ça c'est
quelque chose qui s'est créé sur sur le
long terme et le développement c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui a été
maîtrisé à des moments donnés parce que
avec les nouvelles technologies avec
avec tout ça il ya toujours eu la
réflexion autour de comment structurer
la pédagogie comment ne pas perdre la
main sur sur sur ce que sont aujourd'hui
les jeunes ce que peut être voilà un
improvisateur aujourd'hui penser que
profiter à tort aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on veut apprendre aujourd'hui on lui
apprend à aujourd'hui je pense qu'on en
apprend beaucoup moins de beaba c'est à
dire que à l'époque c'était très
technique il fallait il fallait
comprendre voilà le système d' écoute
mais surtout il fallait
il fallait jouer il fallait qu'on joue
très rapidement aujourd'hui en fait on
est plus sur 1 / / / un questionnement
autour d'eux comment cette pratique là
en fait tu arrives à avoir arrive à
attraper ses lettres de noblesse et du
coup on laisse pas nécessairement
l'improvisation que à l'improvisation
alors que pour être un bon improvisateur
ou pour pouvoir improviser il faut
savoir chanter il faut connaître ses
classiques il faut avoir des nous faut
avoir des notions télévisuelle faut
avoir et en fait il ya quelque chose de
une espèce de complémentarité à faire
autour de beaucoup beaucoup de pratique
nous on a des comédies on est une
comédienne moi je pense à marion voilà
qui est qui et qui a des capacités de
cire qui est ce qui est un moment donné
quand on va mettre tout ce beau monde en
dansant la patinoire et semblait bien on
va créer vraiment un
un quelque chose de c'est comme un feu
d'artifice quoi sa part dans sa part
dans plein de choses et en même temps on
arrive à se ressembler parce qu on est
autour de la même pratique néanmoins
alors avoir un petit excellent du
championnat
intercall âge dont vous vous occupez
notamment qui a lieu qu'elle chaque
année 1,2 après quoi il ya plusieurs
parents oui oui et puis tv 78 ans
j'étais un partenaire privilégié de ce
dispositif
regardez un extrait
championne armada flèche de match
d'harmonisation
[Musique]
explosion de joie pour nathan marie
cyrine nicolas arthur et la lie ce sont
ces collégiens de coignières qui ont été
désignés par le public de la merise pour
remporter le trophée de cette 19ème
édition du cycle need organisé par
déclic théâtre une année de travail
récompensé on n'arrive pas à croire
première année on gagne la première fois
du coup bah c'est super et je sais pas
comment expliquer l enthousiasme c'est
génial gang des femmes à barbe ou encore
un avenir sans avenir
durant la soirée 4 collège de trappes et
long cours montigny le bretonneux et
coignières se sont affrontés sur ces
thèmes d'improvisation pour ces phases
finales quelques règles à respecter
comme la construction de l'histoire et
le respect de la langue française à la
fin de chaque passage le public donne
son verdict pour sa première
participation le collège la mare au sol
a remporté tous les suffrages
ils viennent là avec juste la folie du
jeu est en fait du coup ils sont
complètement détachée de l'enjeu et
c'est ça qui a fait la différence
[Musique]
on a une grosse énergie véritablement
dans les collèges et ça c'est vraiment
très intéressant et au delà de cette
énergie de la créativité de l'imaginaire
cette année le championnat inter
collèges d'improvisation théâtrale a
réuni 15 établissements de saint quentin
en yvelines une participation record qui
pourrait bien augmenter pour la
prochaine édition
ils sont des tâches est dangereux comme
vous deviez mais garrel en scène fait
remarquer que vos cheveux aussi 15 15
collèges les prochaines on ouvre à saint
quentin il faudra trouver un
établissement effectivement qui veut y
participer
c'est important pour nous de créer
détendant l'intercommunale
intercommunalités qui peut y avoir et
puis de créer rassembler les gens voient
territoire c'est un peu comme vous voilà
c'est important de le cibler le
territoire parce que cela alors non mais
mais du coup ce qui est intéressant en
terme de fonds dans notre manière de
véhiculer notre pratique depuis
depuis 1995 on a tous les étés en tout
cas quasiment tous les étés un groupe de
l'adolescent de 15 19 ans qui partent en
tournée on l'a fait moi j'aimerais bien
épaulé c'est à chaque fois un bon
souvenir parce que en fait on 2 c'est à
dire que trappe c'est véhiculé par les
médias d'une certaine manière et c'est
vrai que là on nous pour nous c'est
important d'aller en province et que les
jeunes montrent ce qu'ils savent faire
et qu'ils soient leurs propres médias
assurée et qu'ils puissent montrer c'est
aussi ça c'est aussi ça parce que sinon
on n'entend pas alors il à tv soixante
dix huit pour le dire c'est pas d'autres
buts
quoi qu'il en soit ouais c'est important
pour nous de cet été on les emmène en
haute savoie on a un partenariat
on a déjà monté pour nous c'est très
riche on va faire de l'improvisation
avec des mineurs isolés et du coup on a
nos quinze jeunes de trappes l'acquis
qui vont qui vont qui vont à la
rencontre de d'une association qui
s'appelle le damier qui fait valoir
leurs droits à ces jeunes qui viennent
de différentes régions du monde voilà
qui qui sont réfugiés et qui est à
attendre voilà qui attendent de pouvoir
régulariser ou ou non on verra mais leur
situation
en tout cas c'est une manière aussi pour
nos jeunes devaient d'aller derrière de
créer un moment de fête pour ce n'est
pas ces jeunes là dans le cadre de leur
accueil parce qu on se doit de les
accueillir et en même temps pour nos
jeunes à nouveau de relativiser aussi un
certain nombre de choses sur ce qu'ils
vivent et en dix ans finalement tout va
bien pour nous et c'est super et puis en
plus on s'entend bien même qu'elle se
garait dans cette mi-temps parce qu'il
ya un côté sportif championnat 10 buts
et vous tous aussi parce qu'il ya aussi
des liens entre la culture
je conviens d'un amour / voilà il ya
beaucoup de deux chefs d'entreprise
nouvelle entreprise qui disent bon il
faut avoir une bonne idée vous l'aviez
eu mais ça suffit pas d'avoir validé
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
des bonnes idées après il faut la mener
jusqu'au bout ce que vous ce que vous
avez réussi à faire quand comment et
télé parce que c'est un problème les
investisseurs parce que ça coûte de
l'argent évidemment de ne fonder les ans
comme hendrix
ben je pense que les deux sujets que
vous évoquez sont liés en fait il ya
effectivement avoir l'idée puis
et puis l exécuter alors parler de steve
jobs tout à l'heure pour le garage et
moyens il ya quelque chose que steve
jobs l'a dit j'aime beaucoup c'est il ya
beaucoup de gens qui rêvent de faire des
choses il ya ceux qui restent éveillés
qu'ils les font parce que des bonnes
idées ça c'est bien répartie enfin tout
le monde pour en avoir énormément de
gens qui ont des idées et puis et puis à
ce qui se met en risque pour essayer de
les déployer et les investisseurs adore
ça et en fait alors moi j'ai découvert
ça vous savez tous que vous aviez voix
ben moi j'ai mis tout ce que j'avais à
l'époque activement et g j'ai même
hypothéqué la maison frais l'appartement
de mon papa j'ai vendu mes seins sur la
chance que j'ai c'est que je pense que
je les fais aussi un âge où c'est facile
parce que j'avais pas encore d'enfant
parce que j'avais un tout petit loyer
enfin moment là vous pouvez vous mettre
en risque plus facilement mais vous le
fait quand même
et puis après plus vous avancez bay hill
plus vous le faites et plus les enjeux
sont importants
alors non on était en autofinancement
pendant trois quatre ans et puis après
on s'est dit et si on d'aller chercher
de l'argent peu sur le marché aussi pour
grandir plus vite
et là vous découvrir un domaine que vous
ne connaissez pas du tout c'est encore
une fois on n'apprend pas pour le coup
en terminale es à lever des fonds des
vents mais c'est assez intéressant parce
que parce qu'être super fonds
d'investissement en france et qui adore
les jeunes en fait qui adore les
entrepreneurs et qui sont là pour
débloquer des fonds sur des entités qui
sont plus hautes et qui ont moins la
faculté pour savoir aborder les sujets
et quels sont ceux qui sont prometteurs
et du coup on a une partie du capital
maintenant minoritaires mais qui est
détenu fêtions par des actionnaires
si tu subis des fonds et c'est très
enrichissant aussi parce que ces gens là
vont être énormément de dossiers dans
l'année avec des business modèles très
différents
et quand vous avez certaines questions
sans réponse au quotidien vous pouvez
les appeler les consulter voilà c'est
vraiment y'a un incubateur à 50 ans vous
avez regardé un peu alors via le site
youtube si c'est ça je serais je pour la
semaine prochaine pour
en tant que jurée pour certains oui on
aime beaucoup et moi à titre personnel
je suis investi c'est le moteur
complètement raison gestion qui est là
pour pousser les faire grandir les
jeunes pousses et je disais moi je le
fais aussi à titre personnel chez
investisseurs dans cinq ou six
d'entreprises rue qui sont plus petites
que nous mais qui ont des projets
parfois très différents à jamais dans le
soir oui parce qu'après d'aidé et de
faciliter la vie peut-être d'autres vous
parlez de ram en canoë ont parlé mais
nous on va beaucoup ramé au début pour
faire plein de choses mais on a des gens
qui nous ont fait confiance
j'espère parce qu'on méritait
et aujourd'hui moi je vois des gens plus
jeunes qui se lancent aussi qui parfois
trouve pas les bonne écoute et si on
peut les accompagner que ce soit du
temps où quelques quelques euros on
essaie de le faire aussi c'est hyper
intéressant et c'est hyper oxygénant
pour nos si je pense que c'est ça aussi
est une start up c'est rester à l'écouté
on agile sur tout ce qui se passe autour
alors vous êtes sur le marché français
très fort vous êtes vous êtes aussi
dénoncé un certain nombre de pays à
l'espagne
coupez le l'enjeu pour vous c'est aussi
de dunk au caire des marchés nouveaux
noms ça oui bien sûr la victime les
investissements ça va ça va ça on a une
présence assez forte enfance et ses 85 %
de notre activité aujourd'hui
l'espagne a tout de suite très vite
accroché donc c'est 10 % de notre
activité
et puis les autres pays qu'on livre
assez rapidement son sont effectivement
le paysage qu'on adresse aujourd'hui il
ya un réel enjeu pour nous parce que
c'est assez amusant et il n'y a aucune
critique vous l'enjeu c'est de réussir à
wil et reste sur le plan local plan
local nous c'est d'essayer de casser les
bars à toutes les zones de chalandise
possible et puis et puis en plus de ça
les gaffes à que vous évoquez qui fait
qu'ils sont là pour bien noir et
aujourd'hui on a un modèle en fait qui
par notre plateforme logistique et puis
par le savoir-faire qu'on a réussi à
cultiver en interne nous permet de nous
exporter assez facilement et donc
maintenant l'enjeu c'est de savoir où on
va et dans quels agendas
c'est ça qui est assez amusant aussi
dans une start up c'est qu'on a envie de
tout faire et là où le métier change au
quotidien aussi c'est qu'après il faut
débloquer vous êtes super on ne discute
en vaste table 250 idée voilà mais
quelles sont les bonnes et quels sont
les moyens dont on a besoin pour pour y
parvenir
c'est hyper intéressant et c'est
intéressant et ça prouve que sa vie soit
sa vie énormément c'était ça la
différence vous fait exploser les
frontières et vous c'est vrai que les
territoires sont sont importants pour
pour vous parce que la voie la culture
ça doit être aussi quelque chose qui
permet aux gens de vivre ensemble et
donc il faut bien un petit peu de pas
des frontières mais enfin il faut bien
vos des limites et des territoires
pourquoi ne feriez pas un spectacle à
vélo alors d'abord ceci dit si on
s'était rencontrés avant dans un des
spectacles qu'on a fait une escapade on
n'avait pas ce qu'on a travaillé à la
queue-lez-yvelines où est passé le tour
de france un moment donné on travaille
sur l'histoire
mais on avait envie de faire une scène
comme ça avec des vélos alors on a fait
une récup de vieux vélos mais on n'est
pas allé tout à fait au bout de ce
projet là est ce qu elle ne l était
précise dans enfin de granby c'est le
lieu on peut y aller alors oui à gambais
voilà l'été ça va être un petit peu plus
calme on fait une semaine de chantier
participatif là à partir de mardi si
nous avons voilà ça c'est possible en
tout cas de venir visiter et au mois de
septembre on a beaucoup d'actualité ya
plein de choses qui vont se passer à
grand baie et dans les yvelines photos
sur notre territoire du coup il ya des
événements on va faire notre
anniversaire qu'on fait chaque année au
mois d'octobre
et puis il ya des artistes du collectif
qui font deux événements dans le cadre
d'un dispositif qui s'appelle le
patrimoine aux artistes qui est un
projet mené par le parc naturel régional
de la vallée de chevreuse avec une
projection d'un film sur un sur les
temps d'aider hollande un des étangs des
hollande
et puis il veiller près d'un arbre
centenaire voilà donc des pleins de
choses qui valent chouette il ya un site
un site internet est le lieu point org
et puis vous avez le facebook et puis
voilà c'est nos moyens de communication
principaux merci beaucoup c'est celle de
magna merci beaucoup
vous allez vous accompagnez les le haut
j'accompagne les jeunes du coucher pour
des raisons techniques parce que je suis
directeur de centre de loisirs par
ailleurs donc je suis le seul habilité à
organiser
et puis derrière cette doctrine comme si
vous avez besoin de deux vélos
d'équipements sportifs sous le sol ne
ratez pas ce sont les soldes depuis deux
jours les sols merci infiniment à tous
les trois et demi sur le terme aider on
se retrouve très vite par on fera
peut-être un dernier paf de l'été avant
la rentrée
[Musique]
non juste